et regardez il ya un truc assez
hallucinant c'est que vous avez ça
pouvait enfin je vois ça vous avez un
bar dans l'eau regardez là bas
coiffés en bar dans l'eau
[Musique]
pasqua
je me suis dit que les meilleurs
endroits pour vous parler du nouveau nom
view 20 c'était carrément de le tester
en vacances pourquoi pas alors là on est
parti en république dominicaine pour
quelques jours histoire de profiter un
peu de se refaire une bonne santé de se
faire un un beau bronzage avant de
partir au mwc dans quelques jours à
barcelone pas forcément quand tu vas
dans ce lot il faut être beau donc là on
est plutôt pas mal il fait quelque chose
comme 30° super soleil très beau temps
donc aujourd'hui on va parler du honor
view 20 mai juste avant d'en parler ce
que je propose c'est de retourner au
studio parce que cette vidéo est
sponsorisé par one de chair et justement
je vous parlais d'une solution qui peut
vraiment vous intéresser pour éditer vos
pdf sur iphone en juin je vais vous
présenter un logiciel très intéressant
qui va vous permettre de sortir de
certaines galère lorsque vous voulez
créer éviter et exporter vos pdf
directement sur votre iphone le logiciel
s'appelle premiere elements vous déjà
présenté en version ordinateur
aujourd'hui je vous le montre sur ios et
croyez moi dans l'édition de vos pdf
dans les signatures en ligne dans pas
mal de choses et dans beaucoup de cas d'
usage que vous ne soupçonnez pas ça
pourra franchement vous enlevé une belle
épine du pied des vhu solutionner pas
mal de problèmes par exemple on va se
prendre cette brochure jeu mais là je
clique sur plus je peux le faire soit
que ma caméra soit en wifi je peux
récupérer des documents directement avec
mon adresse local via mon wifi
moi personnellement ce que je vais faire
je le fais avec ma caméra c'est beaucoup
plus simple j'ai pris une photo de mon
document qui se trouve justement là mon
outil il le reconnaît il le recadre
directement sa grogne
ensuite je peut sauvegarder et hop
terminée et là je me retrouve avec mon
lot maupoint pdf et ça c'est franchement
cool
une fois que j'ai la brochure qui est là
je peux venir travailler dessus je peux
dire faire différentes c'est donc là
j'ai tous les outils sur le côté je peux
vous dire par exemple up dessiné dessus
dire tiens up regarde ce petit truc la
marque et un petit message
un petit coucou la gérante par exemple
le guide d'utilisateurs iphone le guide
j'ai envie l'éditer je peux venir
surligner du texte ça ça m'intéresse je
prends je surligne cette partie là elle
n'intéresse hop je la barre non ça je le
veux pas et hop
j'enregistre de la même manière je peux
ensuite venir dessiner directement ici
avec ma gomme je peux venir supprimer ça
qui est pas très très beau j'ai loupé je
peux vraiment venir
complètement limité une fois que j'ai
mon document qui est là et bien c'est
faire le choix de venir le partage est
donc je peux l'envoyer par mail je peut
l'imprimer
je peux le partage et je peux l'ofppt
l'aude et je peux l'envoyer par email
par message le partager sur les réseaux
sociaux l'enregistrer sur mon google
drive je fais tout ce que je veux donc
ça je vous demanderais non sur des
fonctionnalités de base ne vous pouvez
aller beaucoup plus loin au niveau du
travail que vous pouvez faire sur des
pdf directement sur votre iphone c'est
donc une solution très intéressante
c'est presque un indispensable s'il vous
intéresse je vous ai mis un lien en bas
dans la description
je vous invite à les découvrir parce que
franchement ça pourrait bien vous aider
on est descendu au sun skype à puerto
plata je sais que dans beaucoup
d'endroits la météo est pas terrible
ici elle est juste généreuse dans cry
high tech moi on va se rapprocher de là
bas ça va être top
juste à côté de moi là là il va y avoir
un mariage ce soir feu d'artifice à
22h30
regardez ils ont tout prévu pour le
mariage c'est juste à côté de la plage
là on tourne
et là vous avez la place juste derrière
autant vous dire que ça déchire
vous aimez la mer dernier alors c'est
pas la mer c'est l'océan c'est l'océan
atlantique
une mer des caraïbes celle de côté
excusez moi pour les lunettes mais le
soleil tape énormément alors je vous
parle de ce honorio van leeuw normal je
trouve vraiment hyper hyper hyper cool
sur plein de points et déjà le design
signé avec moschino les faits derrière
là l'effet brillant qui se reflète c'est
franchement on va pas se mentir juste
hallucinant il ya un effet juste
magnifique
ça c'est vraiment un très très très gros
point positif la du prof gros point
positif là dessus le fait que vous ayez
toujours la prise jack conserver ça ça
reste aussi un énorme point positif
point positif le fait que vous et de la
recharge rapide je vous parle de
l'autonomie dans quelques instants avec
la prise en lui et ce but il sait ça
c'est franchement énorme
le capteur d'empreintes digitales a
effectué l arrière ne gêne pas même si
c'est vrai que ça aurait pu être bien de
l'avoir directement intégrés sous
l'écran là ce n'est pas le cas on est
sur un écran lcd mais ça aussi je vais
vous le détailler
mais en tout cas d'un point de vue
10 à eelv a pondu extérieur je trouve
que c'est au nord du vin est franchement
réussi pourra retourner sur un
concurrent notamment du wan pu assister
c'est vraiment un smartphone qui est top
[Musique]
on va commencer par parler un peu de
l'écran du haut nord view va parce que
cet écran il est super intéressant
je me laisse un peu venez avec moi voilà
ce qu on pourrait regretter au premier
abord c'est le fait de ne pas avoir d'
écran amoled vu les concurrents phase
qui ont tous des écrans amoled néanmoins
d'un écran lcd qui franchement bien 6,4
pouces de diagonale est ce qui est
surtout très intéressant
salah le petit poinçonnage pas dans
coche fini les encoches au nord a fait
le choix début 2019 de ne pas mettre en
cause justement et de venir mettre ce
petit poisson atteint alors pourquoi est
ce qui nous met ce poinçonnage là
excusez moi je goûte pourquoi nous
mettre ce petit poinçonnage là enfin
compte l'idée elle est toute simple
c'est de se dire
j'enlève l'encoche c'est la fin des
encoches néanmoins je regardais une
caméra à l'avant caméra vous l'avez mais
justement pourquoi ne pas la mettre au
centre tout simplement pour des
questions de jeu parce que lorsque vous
allez jouer à des jeux vous allez tenir
votre smartphone exactement dans cette
position-là et du coup votre petit
poisson nage va disparaître alors au
début je vous cache pas qu'on le regarde
c'est vrai qu'on le regarde mais très
rapidement on oublie sa position on
oublie qu'il est l'un et c'est
franchement pas dérangeant de la même
manière lorsque vous allez regarder des
vidéos on s'habitue on a l'impression
d'avoir un écran plus grand plus
immersif il reste néanmoins cette petite
position ce petit point sonna comme je
tombe à pour la caméra mais ça pose
absolument aucun problème voyez là
typiquement se répartit da soit ni trop
et j'ai même mon personnage qui hellip
mon jeu ne vient pas jusque là alors
imaginons par exemple que j'ai un job je
tiens comme ça j'ai fui la voyez sous
mon doigt ça disparaît carrément qu'est
ce que j'ai fait j'ai explosé de la
bagnole
voyez par exemple sera soit ni trop ça
disparaît complètement
lorsque je freinais alors le but de ce
fait ni trop ce n'est pas de freiner
mais si je veux freiné par exemple ça
disparaît complètement
et ça c'est pas mal alors c'est vrai que
c'est beaucoup plus immersif c'est pas
la solution idéale
néanmoins c'est cool alors fait d'avoir
ce grand écran comme ça c'est bien pour
ça mais c'est aussi bien pour regarder
des vidéos
je vous dis au début on a tout dit un
petit peu attiré par ça mais après ça
disparaît ou assez rapidement cet écran
lcd pas mal mais là voyages coûteux
luminosité forage me met vraiment en
plein soleil là donc on est vraiment
sous un soleil de plomb alors moi quand
je le regarde comme ça c'est vrai que je
vois c'est pas trop mal mais vous à la
caméra c'est un peu compliqué alors
c'est quand même assez lumineux on voit
quand même ce qui se passe mais c'est
vrai que c'est globalement pas idéal et
ça ça peut être aussi un peu le
peut-être le point de regret l'écran
manque légèrement mais légèrement
de luminosité et là on se prépare pas en
mariage bravo félicitations
sinon globalement l'écran je sois pas
mal il tire un peu vers le bleu alors ça
on peut très très très facilement venir
le corriger dans les paramètres dans les
paramètres d'affichage dans ce que vous
êtes là il faut aller dans mode de
température et de couleurs et là vous
pouvez venir corriger à côté de ça et de
la résolution de l'écran je la trouve
vraiment énorme la qualité vraiment bien
vous êtes sur du full hd + 19 points 5/9
d'horatio la partie écran
la partie multimédia la partie jeux
vidéo ça pour moi sans point vraiment
très très positif alors maintenant qu'en
est-il en termes de performances ça
c'est quand même une bête de compet on a
un qui rinne 980 qu'elle derniers stocks
de silicone qui est gravé en 7
nanomètres qui marche super bien vous
avez deux versions soit 6 giga de ram
soit 8 gigas de ram tout ça va vous
apporter vraiment de la fluidité un
smartphone sur lequel vous allez pouvoir
jouer à des jeux vous allez sentir
aucune latence le smartphone est fluide
c'est agréable ça c'est franchement toc
après là où il faut faire gaffe c'est en
termes de stockage parce que vous avez
deux versions non extensible 68 soit 256
j'ai bien le fait que ce soit pas
extensible ça te poser des problèmes
pour les grands consommateurs de
stockage notamment de photos donc fait
vraiment gaffe réfléchit c'est vraiment
ce que vous voulez dès le début si vous
voulez pas voir déconvenue très
clairement pour moi en tout cas en ce
qui concerne 128 gars ça suffira mais ça
ne suffira pas forcément à tout le monde
il faut vraiment éviter ce problème là
vous avez le gpu turbo version 2.0 ça
carbure c'est fluide c'est vraiment duo
gagnant pour moi ça c'est vraiment un
énorme point positif au niveau de
smartphones et autres points qui est
positif c'est lorsque vous allez rire
autant plus une batterie de 4000
millions terreur vous allez voir une
autonomie complètement incroyable
l'autonomie est excellente
il ne vient pas uniquement de la
batterie mais là vraiment de
l'optimisation logicielle qui est faite
parce que vous avez déjà le keirin 980
qui est extrêmement performant qui va
vraiment permettre d'avoir un gain en
termes d'autonomie tout s'accoupler avec
du gpu turbo c'est franchement aussi
extraordinaire donc le fait que vous
ayez une énorme batterie un souk aient
complètement optimisé avec en plus de la
ram derrière avec une optimisation
software grâce au gpu turbo ça vous
donne un smartphone qui est vraiment
endurant vous allez pouvoir emmener sur
un jour et demi sans aucun problème
voire même deux jours et pourquoi plus
en fonction de votre utilisation en plus
de ça ce qui est franchement cool c'est
qu'ils nous ont mis de la recharge
rapide en gros en à peine une demi heure
vous à les recharger
à plus de 50% et si vous voulez une
recharge complète il faut un peu moins
d'une heure et demie ça c'est
franchement génial je vais garder pour
plus tard la partie si vous m'en voulez
pas trop photo vidéo tout simplement
parce qu'il ya quand même beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de choses à dire le
fait notamment que vous ayez un seul
capteur à l'arrière et une caméra trois
dimensions à côté ça c'est assez
intéressant donc ça ans la guerre pour
un peu plus tard enfin quelques jours
parce qu'on l'a testée ici au soleil
donc croyez moi ça va envoyer du steak
maintenant il ya aussi une nouveauté
dans ce smartphone et qui est assez cool
c'est la première fois qu'on a un magic
your way et non pas eu est mu ou et moi
y est moyen comme vous voulez de de
huawei donc ça c'est intéressant alors
très clairement comme ça à première vue
c'est bien l'appellation chant jordi
goût on a un truc un peu nouveau
s'écoulent dans les faits ce n'est pas
le cas dans les faits c'est la même
chose c'est le même environnement s'est
même écosystème
j'imagine que d'ici quelques temps
peut-être que les deux environnements
vont changer pour vraiment avoir de
monde réellement séparer tout de suite
ce n'est pas le cas il ya en tout cas un
changement on le voit de parole non ça
veut dire qu'il ya une vraie volonté
derrière de la part de huawei honor par
contre on voit qu'il ya une vraie
volonté de changement et d'évolution
quand on arrive sur équilibre digital et
ça c'est un truc qu'on retrouvait déjà
dans le google pixels 3 ce qu'ils
appellent chez google le bien-être
numérique alors entre bien-être
numérique et l'équilibré j talent que
veulent nous dire les marques ce qui va
nous dire c'est qu'ils ont compris le
message que les gens veulent plus être
considérés comme des consommateurs base
on vient on croit votre cerveau et on
essaye de vous optimisez la partie
software pour vous restez connectés un
maximum de temps ils vous consommiez
vous consommez vous consommiez que votre
cerveau sont complètement inspirée par
la machine il ya une vraie prise de
conscience en disant aujourd'hui des
fabricants veulent vraiment que le temps
que vous alliez passer soit un temps
conscient que vous ne soyez pas
uniquement happés par des facebook par
des instincts gran par des snapshots par
des youtube ou parce que vous voulez que
vous ayez vraiment conscience dans vos
papiers dessus et que ce soit du temps
de qualité en gros vous vous l'aviez pas
le cerveau pour être tout le temps
consommateurs consommateurs qui est par
contre en suisse aussi bien et qu'on va
vraiment dans le bon sens tout
simplement parce que on va chercher un
peu plus à éduquer parce que moi j'adore
la technologie sans leurs parents
d'ailleurs mais je suis un très grand
fan de technologie sinon je serais pas
là en train de vous en parler
aujourd'hui
mais le vrai problème qu'il ya c'est que
nos jeunes des apparences dans les mains
les smartphones il ya à peine
disant voir un tout petit peu plus on
était très heureux mais pas forcément
prêt en tout cas prêt à se rendre compte
vraiment des dangers qu'on a derrière
ces écrans derrière ces smartphones
derrière tous les appareils qu'on
utilise en termes de technologie c'est à
dire qu'au final on est happé par ce
monde là on a besoin de décrocher on a
besoin de pouvoir se rendre compte du
temps qu'on passe dessus et c'est
justement ça qui est hyper intéressant
avec notamment ses petites partie
software vous n'êtes pas obligé
d'utiliser en tout cas c'est vraiment
bien qu'elle soit là et je pense que ça
va dans le bon sens parce que ça permet
d'éduquer le consommateur et lui
permettre de se rendre compte que des
fois on passe beaucoup trop de temps on
a besoin que de se reconnecter avec le
réel c'est ça paraît il à son fabuleux
mais ils doivent pas nous déconnecter du
monde avec voilà j'arrête un peu on en
reparlera une prochaine fois on est donc
sur un smartphone que je trouve
franchement franchement franchement
génial je sais pas si vous aimez ça
directement commentaire le boulot qui a
été fait derrière en terme de design
comment vous le trouvez moi je le trouve
vraiment magnifique pour un peu négatif
c'est qu'on a juste un haut parleur mono
qui se situe là le haut parleur qui
hélas n'est pas du tout utilisé c'est
quand même dommage parce qu'on est un
smartphone qui est vachement immersif et
on perd un peu en immersion en termes
d'audio même si on le sait quand on
utilise ces haut parleurs là vous n'avez
pas des mêmes gras vous allez plus
d'aigus et médium
néanmoins cela m'aidera à porter quand
même un petit peu de son c'est peut être
pas mal voilà ça c'est un peu peut-être
le point un petit peu négatif
bon maintenant je vous laisse me dire ce
que vous en pensez vous en bas en
commentaire est ce que vous aimez bien
le interview vin est ce que vous trouvez
que au nord a fait un excellent boulot
sur ce produit le nordiste est déjà très
très très bon l'année dernière en plus
ce qui est bien c'est que ça montre
vraiment vraiment là où on va aller
cette année la disparition l'encoche
petit à petit on s'en approche doucement
trait sur les solutions qui paraissent
plus intéressante aux réfractaires de
l'encoche donc ça c'est franchement
hyper hyper hyper cool et puis on va les
voir toutes ces solutions j'ai déjà
montré le jour celle de hisense on va
aller voir pascal aussi plein plein
plein d'autres solutions qui existent et
qui vont arriver cette année
d'ailleurs on va les voir ces quelques
jours au mwc sachez entraîne le quai on
sale est vraiment cool on va aller à
barcelone
on va voir plein de choses ensemble et
puis là on va qui fait un peu maintenant
parce que ici c'est l'été on est au mois
de janvier on est quoi exactement
laissez moi vous dire on est le 30
janvier à puerto plata il fait 29 degrés
on n'est pas mal
je sais qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
beaux coups de mauvais temps en france
donc voilà donc là j'ai me rapprocher de
justine et d'hélium qui sont au bord de
la piscine
il ya pas mal de monde
donc on va aller tranquille où
s'installer au bord de la piscine
je vais nager un peu là dedans et
regardez il ya un truc assez hallucinant
c'est que vous avez ça pour ma part je
vois ça vous avait pas de barre dans
l'eau regardez là bas
c'est en bombardant le ici c'est génial
parce que l'on peut aller dans la
piscine directement avec son verre à la
main vous faites ça n'importe quel
camping n'importe quel hôtel en france
vous fait jeter ici vous faites pas
jeter c'est franchement plutôt cool
voilà comme ça vous découvrez un peu les
joies de la république dominicaine danse
avec un espèce de sang ouais tu viens
voir
[Musique]